welcome to this video against true
Shanghai 008 mmm yeah this is the guy
that I played before us yeah those good
numbers numbers at the other always a
bit irritating you never know maybe they
made a new account and I back and or
whatever no way this is a guy I've
played before actually 13 times with a
minus 1 score yeah okay i'm playing into
the Queen's Indian an opening for white
that I have never played in tournament
chess I always some basically always on
went form for 93 and allowed the new
zone but I want to vary a little bit
them and get some experience with those
positions but I'm pretty much yeah I
don't really know it so I know that this
is aligned 97 I think yeah I know the
Quai think rookie one this is this is a
what i have seen before intending afore
and now black takes and play specially
form but I that that's all I know hmm ok
so it did not take more interesting now
I can play for which chef should be
there the idea of all of that good okay
let's do that sorry this is a first game
and I'm kind of not yet accustomed to
talking if you this is the these are the
first towards you going to going to
speak the whole day ok so it's attacking
me for quite a couple of times but I
have it protected huh that looks
actually kind of weird
ok Annette centralized it can hardly be
bad okay what is he going to do looky a
door I mean even if five is that it's
something that is very very much
possible maybe five de five yallop
rookie 85g five don't I have some
discoveries there that germ are quite
annoying oh yeah I don't see a tactic at
the moment if I've DEA I mean whatever
square i go to its not giving okay i can
go to a fire film and then take you five
with the bishop that's not bad let's do
that maybe I'm okay I could have played
f3 maybe that's better it's sometimes
hard to tell f3 is definitely better for
wine instead of e5 I mean I have a big
center i have the bishop pair
everything's good but it might pass up
on on a chance to do something yeah
directly however i did not really
calculate this to them to a definite
conclusion you know here was thinking
night f5 should be good yeah let's do
that ideas to just take on e5 with the
bishop and then get this pressure going
on the Kings side
you know I think yeah Quincy eight looks
kind of a normal I am interesting yeah I
can't actually think of Bishop age three
he might just move the king and then
it's not clear if I have a decent
discovery with the night I probably
don't if i take here yeah okay I'm going
to take I'm going to take for Bishop f6
or night h6 yeah I don't have to take on
g2 immediately I can play Bishop s6 i
guess in intermediate move let's let's
do that on not it moves I can play be
sure before maybe which you might not
lead to much
I interesting him after if I take with
the king he can play night to you form
which should be ok so Bishop f6b should
before yeah ok let's do that it's
probably okay for him somehow maybe I'm
missing something it's possible of
course I think we should be for now is
what I expect at least
or does he have something crazy Bishop
Bishop h three or so I don't don't don't
get it I don't believe it I mean okay
here i was thinking I Teague and play
then 97 for a quality I guess that's not
okay i can click on this happening with
the night this is any good or take here
for the trades Queenie 494 night is
having check and then I'd c8 sure it's
nothing nothing much going on check okay
has to go to f8 I cannot click on g7
unfortunately or you can take it I can
take my bishop no then I Floop the a-ok
a while it was the shaky calculation I
think Luke the age should be sufficient
somehow maybe not our kind of rock da
this is ok and ok just takes with that
if I check him yeah I kind of can't have
to that's it's a funny position that's a
funny position
yeah I don't know what is he doing f6
king of 75 96 and he's in a pin it's
really really a strange position I
cannot go to e4 because of the check
that much is clear so I have to have to
avoid rook a3 check I guess and this is
also running into 96 check time morning
so I'm doing here oh I did not think
about that at all hmm ok so we unpinned
in that way isn't there any way to use
the spin on the eighth-ranked yeah I
don't see it ok yeah I spent far too
much time also
I am that I didn't play that well it was
definitely okay at some point check very
very strange very strange position check
check 20 seconds but ok the position is
of course also pretty much lost check
I can just take two three okay and it
was very intricate reason was very
tricky yeah of course I mean here I'm
just just just better but I didn't that
didn't really didn't really find the the
way to do it okay so the key is I should
take on b7 first yeah I wasn't sure
about that this is actually the leading
to the to the big advantage yeah okay
Queen takes and then Bishop to examine
this reduces his counter play ideas
based on the hanging state of this night
when the queen is on see aid and now
this is actually really uncomfortable
fun because of this threads like night
h6 Bishop f6 and so on this is the best
line according to the comp which has the
97 idea as well that's very nice for
whiter it's very difficult for him to
move even this is what the comp gives
with plus 1.5 about check and this yeah
it should be it should have been better
because of my much better development
and and the better piece there on g on
c3 yeah this is this is pretty awkward
it can hardly move any of his pieces
yeah okay so that was that was the key
moment there I actually my original
intention was to just recapture but then
I saw that this one is working and two
there's two pieces are hanging so I went
with this we should be ok but I screwed
up afterwards of course takes takes yeah
and he I should just play 97 and keep it
simple 94a Queenie for was not a good
idea sending my piece there um sending
my piece there under the strange post
down this is this is a simple way to
play
and here why this not not having much
but at least can claim my bishop is
better than the night I don't know maybe
it's suggest should be equal right i
mean the night only six is pretty well
placed keeping c7 protected everything
yeah that's about equal yeah but after
that at least gets tricky and it might
be okay for me but it chan yeah okay so
well here the computer actually says
that i'm basically winning but how a
four is the move okay killing the
counter play and i didn't I did not
understand this position already laminar
Kim f6 and again a4 I have to play it
for now that that said that that is that
is something that did not understand at
all I have to play I have to play this
and freeze the queenside yeah dad this
is this is really much much better here
once you see it you appreciate the idea
now he has a hard time to move anything
he cannot move anything on the queenside
and yeah he's almost stalemated in this
position it's very difficult um yes they
mated zoosk long as up Smaug is the
right right word it's very difficult for
him to move here it cannot move the
Queen's that he can play it stuff like
that but he's otherwise pretty much
pinned down and I can go F for King up
and March the whole push the whole thing
forward yeah that's very much this is
what I wanted to do but that did not
figure a form that a for was coming and
all of a sudden he had the counter play
he has no counter play okay i know he
cannot do much here i know and and I'm
kind of or maybe h3h five
I'm not quite sure what he's supposed to
do yeah I'm here invading I only have to
avoid this move maybe has to play c5
really and trying to try to hold it dead
maybe it's a draw because of this crazy
situation on the eighth-ranked
the computer is giving white one plus
something but I think that's wrong it is
of course it looks better for white but
how am I ever going to get rid of the
pin I don't think I can win you ever it
looks nice but it is a fortress yeah but
I have to play a form after a fall all
the chances i would white and the only
question is how is black going toward
there maybe he has to play c52 to do
this block pretty quickly avoid anything
in this regard and then maybe maybe
maybe key is some key is something else
actually if we go here maybe I should
start with G for in this position to
avoid any f5 business yeah that's maybe
a good idea and then here here let's say
and he is kind of shuffling and I go air
for this looks this looks promising I
again s f5 if I go f5 myself maybe let's
say something like that now that much
that my twin actually if I get get the
pawn to f5 because now I don't really
see how he is avoiding that i invade
here with like everything i could say
look here here here and I'm going up I'm
just I'm just threatening King up to age
sticks the headwinds I had an
interesting ending that's really
interesting so the key was that that
around here i played this update in the
tikati it took a moment there but i did
not really didn't think actively about
the position i really have to play for
him interesting he spotted that that was
very nice a form and now things are
getting getting complicated and tricky
definitely tricky i couldn't manage to
find anything right here with the time
yeah ok computer says still draw are
here here 96 wins I know I was intact
technically to alert in this game this
wins for what d7 crazy what a crazy
crazy position I'm promoting it's
unbelievable something like that now I
didn't see that yeah I didn't have much
time though check Angie it was just a
time time scramble but the interesting
moment she is really that that I should
play a fourth that's really something to
take from this game a form that's very
instructive killing every kind of
counter play and getting this position
to be very one-sided I think maybe if he
has to play f5 here to prevent g4 I
might have this this thing like H form
and I know he's shuffling again maybe
I'm missing some defensive idea i don't
know but i think he can really just
shuffle look here yeah that's that's not
good um like maybe here I cannot take
out because of maybe I can I thought 96
I'm sorry I cannot do that I can't take
at 5am is always just pinned ya then
then f5 is also not defending him
interesting okay i hope you like this
with an interesting game actually that
was interesting okay well thanks for
watching